for the inu people the magpie river is
our history
is our land
it's our
medicine plan it's our food it's our
water
the magpie river is
everything for us
flowing through the rugged canadian
shield and lush boreal forests of
eastern quebec the magpie lives up to
its reputation as one of the province's
last great wild rivers
but this extraordinary body of water is
now known for something else
it's the first ecosystem in canada to be
granted the same legal rights as a
person
we traveled to a remote area of quebec
to meet the unlikely alliance of people
behind the river's new bill of rights
my grandmother she's 82 now
and she used to live all years on the
land
up until the 1960s the inuvi kwaneshi
first nation lived a nomadic lifestyle
following the caribou inland in the
winter and traveling down the rivers to
the coast in the summer
lydia mistokocho paradise works here at
the local cultural center all the
history that the elders are talking
about
it's there it's not just a physical
thing it's the spirit of the the land
the river the trees and she gave us a
lot so
that's why we have to protect her
this is what they're worried about
this massive hydroelectric development
on the nearby romaine river produces
enough green energy to power nearly half
a million homes in quebec for a year but
it also flooded hundreds of square
kilometers of forest altering the river
and the landscape forever
it's a loss that has had a profound
impact on georgette mistokocho's family
rexa
as ground was being broken on the
romaine river hydro quebec began
exploring similar plans for the magpie
the project never came to fruition but
the threat galvanized people to activate
in a regional alliance with
environmentalists and municipal
officials
[Music]
and so in february 2021 came the
historic move
two parallel resolutions by the inu
council of equanishi and the regional
government of mingani
they granted the river nine rights
including the right to flow and the
right to sue
you know the rights of nature you could
say is a way to essentially bring that
indigenous value system
into western structures of law mari
margil is one of the leaders of the
rights of nature movement over the last
decade forests rivers and lakes from new
zealand to colombia have been granted
legal personhood rights
there's sort of this growing consensus
that environmental laws
are not
enough to protect nature nature is
considered rightless under the law under
most legal systems which means that
nature is in this sort of category of
being considered
a commodity
property
in it
legal persons have rights and
responsibilities and also possess the
ability to sue and be sued
but a legal person doesn't have to be
human for example corporations are
considered legal persons as are churches
and ships
with personhood rights ecosystems would
no longer be seen under the law as an
object to be owned and exploited but
rather a legal subject with its own
rights if you have for instance a
corporation that's polluting a river
violating the rights of that river to be
a healthy thriving ecosystem a
government or people on the ground can
seek to enforce those rights not only on
behalf of the river but in the name of
the river itself and if the river's
rights are upheld in court the
corporation would have to stop polluting
the river and could even have to pay to
restore it back to a healthy state
the magpie river case marks the first
time in the movement's history that the
rights of an ecosystem were recognized
by an indigenous community and a
non-indigenous community simultaneously
that's a really important step forward
but it can't simply be indigenous
peoples taking it forward
this is about western cultures as well
needing to recognize how their
culture their economies and so forth are
deeply impacting the health of the
natural world
luke noel is the top elected official
for the region of mingani he oversaw the
county's resolution on the rights of the
magpi river
luke sees ecotourism as the future
economic driver of the region and says
the county is prepared to fight for the
river even if that means going to court
uh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
people from all over the world come here
for white water rafting expeditions with
danny pellet whose company boreal river
adventures runs on the magpie
it's quite a hike to get to the banks of
the river but danny and his friend
sylvan roi volunteered to show us the
way
[Music]
so this is magpie falls
nice place to build the dam
[Music]
this is a world-class river
incredible nature really clean water
really good fishing the air is
super fresh um and the terrain around
here is really dramatic
and then as you go through the rapids
you kind of really
feel the water splashing on you so i
guess it's like an experience of really
connecting with the place but also with
yourself and with your
senses there aren't many places like
this
left
expanding legal personhood rights to a
river or a forest is a revolutionary
concept
and even its advocates understand that
this could hinder growth in a country
like canada but say there is a bigger
economic picture
we are seeing the impacts from things
like global warming climate change
species extinction which are having
very extreme economic impacts we have
this
i think really
false notion
of what's actually occurring on planet
earth
we are today
destroying the very fabric of life upon
which we depend
and we kind of act like we have a luxury
about whether or not
we decide to protect nature as if it's a
choice
b